[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré au discours de l'Union d'Ursula
fenderlion discours dans lequel la
présidente de la Commission européenne
arborant un tailleur aux couleurs de
l'Ukraine affiché son soutien à Kiev
haut les naza que vous voyez la première
dame ukrainienne était invitée l'Europe
est mise à l'épreuve de cette guerre une
Europe aux valeurs démocratique qui doit
rester solidaire face aux autocraties à
marteler Ursula vanderlayion une Europe
qui doit encore renforcer son
indépendance énergétique alors que
peut-on retenir de son discours comment
l'Europe se transforme-t-elle face à la
guerre en Ukraine comment peut-elle
défendre ses valeurs démocratiques et
comment peut-elle faire face à la crise
énergétique et affirmer son indépendance
on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés Valérie
drézet humez bonsoir vous êtes chef de
la représentant de la représentation de
la Commission européenne en France
bienvenue à vous dans le débat on passe
en face de vous Sabine tilet bonsoir à
vous
la député MoDem et présidente de la
commission des affaires européennes à
l'Assemblée nationale merci Sabine Tila
d'être avec nous également on attend un
troisième invité qui a un peu de retard
François Germaine qui est spécialiste de
géopolitique de l'environnement et
membre du GIEC vous pouvez comme tous
les soirs tous les jours d'ailleurs
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux donc sur
le hashtag débat F24
ours sous la forme c'était donc ce matin
elle a affiché son soutien à l'Ukraine
je vous le disais et une fermeté à
l'égard de la Russie que peut-on retenir
de son discours on fait d'abord le point
avec Marc poop
toute de bleu et de jaune vêtue
Ursula vanderleyen et plusieurs membres
du Parlement européen rendent hommage à
l'Ukraine pour son discours sur l'état
de l'Union la présidente de la
commission a invité et la première dame
ukrainienne au les nazes Hélène ska
l'occasion pour Bruxelles de réaffirmer
sa solidarité indéfectible envers
[Applaudissements]
lettre très clair les sanctions sont
faites pour durer
nous devons être déterminés ce n'est pas
l'heure de l'apaisement
et je me tiens d'ici devant vous
convaincu qu'avec le courage et la
solidarité nécessaire Poutine tombera et
l'Ukraine et l'Europe l'emporteront
la guerre en Ukraine a chamboulé les
perspectives européennes notamment sur
la question de l'énergie pour faire face
à l'envolée des prix l'UE plaide pour
une réforme non profondeur du marché de
l'électricité bruxelles veut ainsi
découpler les prix de l'électricité et
du gaz et surtout plafonner les revenus
des producteurs de l'électricité
produite par les énergies renouvelables
et le nucléaire
en ces temps les profits doivent être
partagés et distribués à ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin
les entreprises productrices d'énergie
fossiles vont devoir payer une
contribution de crise en tout nos
propositions vont permettre de lever 140
milliards d'euros afin de permettre aux
pays membres de supporter au mieux cette
situation
Ursula également discuter avec le
président ukrainien de la poursuite de
l'aide européenne les ministres de
l'énergie européen se réuniront le 30
septembre pour se prononcer sur le plan
d'urgence de la Commission
vous arrivez de Strasbourg donc vous
n'êtes plus président de la commission
des affaires européennes à l'Assemblée
nationale mais a toujours membre de
cette commission c'est le troisième
discours d'Ursula Anders c'était
l'ancienne ministre des Affaires
étrangères d'Angela Merkel pour recamper
un peu son personnage qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de son discours elle a fait
preuve tout de même d'émotion puisque
elle a utilisé la présence justement de
la femme de vaux-le-dimir Zelinski et
également la présence de famille qui
accueille des réfugiés Ukrainiens donc
elle a bien montré d'emblée que l'Europe
était engagée auprès des Ukrainiens
alors moi est-ce que vous a convaincu ce
qui m'a marqué ce qui a marqué en fait
notre délégation on était une vingtaine
de membres de la commission des affaires
européennes de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est qu'on a quand même l'impression
qu'on cause la faune online incarne ce
qu'elle a dit et elle a quand même
cette capacité de se mettre en lien et
de passer aussi de l'émotion et c'est
quelque chose que pendant des années
qu'on n'a pas fait je veux dire passer
une émotion quelque chose de d'humain
c'est adressé à olana Oyonnax et à la
fin aussi aux deux femmes polonaises qui
ont beaucoup est vrai aussi pour
accueillir des Ukrainiens là il y a
quelque chose qui se passe et par
ailleurs ça c'est assez nouveau au
Parlement de Strasbourg je trouve oui et
par ailleurs quand même une fermeté
toujours
assumée ce rôle géopolitique de la
commission donc elle vous a convaincu
comment est-ce que justement les oraux
les démocraties européennes
peuvent-elles vraiment faire le poids
face à Vladimir Poutine ça veut dire en
tout cas ne pas renoncer aux sanctions
ça allait éclaire là-dessus déjà par
notre unité c'est à dire aussi par le
fait aussi peut-être d'accepter
certaines sacrifices bien sûr ce n'est
pas évident de passer ce message mais on
se bat aussi pour notre manière de vivre
quand elle part de la démocratie de
l'État de droit c'est quelque chose
quand même très important après la
deuxième guerre mondiale qu'est-ce qu'on
a essayé de faire en fait dans l'Union
européenne je le dis à chaque fois on a
essayé de faire en à ce que le pouvoir
ne plus plus jamais prendre le pas sur
le droit est-ce que Poutine essaye de
faire c'est que le pouvoir écrase le
droit et ça on ne devrait jamais laisser
passer
vous êtes vous êtes d'accord elle a été
convaincante pour vous recevoir layonne
tout à fait pas seulement parce que ma
fonction me porte à le dire mais
clairement je pense que c'était
important et que Sabine qui laisse
soulignait c'est cette incarnation d'une
Europe d'une Europe forte une envie
d'une communauté humaine aussi qui s'est
levée ensemble face à une autocratie
face à des droits qui sont l'ADN même de
l'Union européenne qui ont été piétinées
et de dire on est capable de le faire
ensemble nos solidarités a été repris à
de multiples reprises et en disant avec
cette solidarité cette unité et cette
fermeté sur nos valeurs nous avons des
solutions elles sont européennes et
elles sont proches elles répondent aux
préoccupations des citoyens européens
parliez d'énergie c'est une dimension
très importante on va revenir justement
sur l'énergie mais vous parlez sacrifice
l'Europe est-ce qu'elle peut mener ses
combats par exemple on sait que
Victor urban en Hongrie à une politique
différente qu'il s'est d'ailleurs qu'il
importe toujours son gaz du côté de
Moscou également la Bulgarie ou la
Serbie qui ménage Moscou on voit bien
que l'Europe est quand même un peu
divisée donc est-ce qu'elle peut
vraiment maintenir ce cap jusque là elle
a réussi à le mettre elle maintenir avec
citron de sanctions adoptée en temps
record avec une unité une unanimité y
compris de certains de certains pays
membres que vous citez effectivement
c'est un défi
ils ont voté les trains de sanction si
si tout à fait 27 à l'unanimité ces
fonctions ont été votées donc maintenant
ce qui va être effectivement le grand
défi c'est de maintenir dans le temps et
on voit au niveau des opinions publiques
certains tendances et notamment qui sont
instrumentalisées par certains partis
qui vont dans cette direction donc le
message de la
quelque soit en Europe on voit un
certain nombre de déclarations qui
focalisent sur sur des faits inexactes
et c'était important que la prise en
trapèle ce matin l'efficacité des
sanctions l'importance de les maintenir
parce que c'est ça qui met qui va mettre
à bas la machine la guerre russes ça
m'étile elle a vous parler de guerre de
la formation en fait c'est vous êtes
d'accord avec il y a effectivement une
instrumentalisation peut-être la part de
certains partis ou favorable en Europe
clairement entendu par certains qui
mettent quand même en cause les sanction
et qui dit c'est nous décisions qui sont
à l'origine des difficultés que nous
vivons aujourd'hui alors que on est
beaucoup à dire non à l'origine c'est
les agissements de Vladimir Poutine par
contre ce qui est
efficaces
aussi avec nous-mêmes tous nos
fonctionnent pas non plus à merveille
dans l'Union européenne et quand la
fondament dit corruption attention il
faut peut-être qu'on aille un peu plus
loin qu'on regarde aussi ce qui se passe
chez nous justement l'État de droit par
rapport à la Hongrie à la Pologne
vont être mises en place à partir du
week-end elle avait affirmé quand même
la conditionnalité j'allais dire à ce
que le budget de l'Union doit être
protégée et les fonds qui sont versés
soit soumises à conditionnalité ça veut
dire au respect de l'État de droit et je
pense que ça c'est quand même un levier
mais simplement faut aussi qu'on ait le
courage de le faire ça veut dire
qu'effectivement vite en bas ne recevra
pas peut-être les fonds ça concrètement
c'est comme ça que ça va se passer si
effectivement les conditions qui ont été
fixées ne sont pas remplies ce serait
effectivement le résultat il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'infractions qui ont été qui ont été
poussés par la Commission européenne
contre les agissements notamment que de
Victor Hormann au niveau de la liberté
de la presse des organisations non
gouvernementales donc c'est une
attention qui est constante depuis
certaines années je crois qu'on parlait
de courage et de volonté de regarder
clairement de manière clairvoyante ce
qui se passe dans notre pré carré si je
veux dire on le fait et la présidente là
notamment mentionné avec une lutte
contre la correction renforcée puisque
dans le rapport sur l'état de droit de
cet été c'était une dimension très
importante qui demande encore du travail
on va regarder justement les réactions
de la France insoumise vous avez dû y
assister en direct Sabine Tillet à la
brandi justement à Strasbourg les
factures d'énergie de particuliers et
vous allez écouter également la réponse
dure cela fond de derrière
alors pour vous les rappeler madame
je suis venu ici avec les factures que
des citoyens m'ont demandé de vous
montrer
celle-là celle de Gilles qui a vu le
prix de son électricité augmentée de 113
euros par mois et qui accompagne son
message par je ne suis pas sûr de me
chauffer cet hiver celle de Grégoire
2300 euros de factures de gaz on à peine
6 mois et puis je pourrais en citer
plein d'autres celle de Brigitte ici qui
se demande si elle va devoir arrêter de
manger ou de s'éclairer cet hiver quand
je regarde ma dame Aubry et les factures
qu'elles nous a montré c'est vrai en
français on dirait elles sont
insupportables c'est vrai mais envoyer
ses factures à Moscou parce que c'est à
eux qu'il faut les envoyer c'est eux qui
sont à la source de nos problèmes c'est
très ferme contre Moscou mais un
commentaire justement votre réaction
lorsque vous avez assisté
en tant que député national on est en
première ligne je veux dire dans ma
circonscription aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui ont
effectivement ces problèmes il y a des
entreprises qui voient leur facture
d'électricité exploser mais je crois que
tout le monde est conscient et
ose la fin de l'année quand même des
choses sur la table pour justement
essayer de limiter entre guillemets je
peux me permettre de dire les dégâts
comme le fait aussi une entre
gouvernement les choses ne peuvent pas
par contre
avoir un effet immédiat comme ça comme
c'est souvent demander et là il faut
qu'on arrête de polémiquer autour de ça
on devrait plutôt être dans la cohésion
et aller voir tous ensemble ce qu'on
peut faire mais justement est-ce qu'il
va pas y avoir une lassitude de la part
des populations qui effectivement vont
voir leur facture augmenter lorsqu'on
entend même Elizabeth borne et on va y
revenir elle parle de est-ce que l'hiver
sera doux ou pas si l'hiver est rude et
qu'effectivement la population
européenne va devoir payer beaucoup plus
cher son chauffage ou même ne pourra
plus chauffer parce que les factures
sont trop élevées est-ce que justement
ils ne vont pas dire arrêtons les
sanctions trouvons autre chose on voit
déjà les prémices de cette lassitude et
c'est pour ça que la Commission réagit
mais elle n'a pas attendu aujourd'hui
non plus je veux dire dès 2021 la
dimension impacte sur les ménages les
ménages et les entreprises étaient déjà
au cœur de l'action c'est pour ça
notamment que la France a pu mettre en
place ce bouclier tarifaire donc c'est
permis par la réglementation européenne
justement pour protéger le consommateur
que de nouvelles mesures sont mises sur
la table mais sont actuellement débattus
notamment vendredi dernier il avait une
réunion des conseils du Conseil des
ministres de l'énergie ils auront
rendez-vous le 30 septembre et il y a
vraiment un bouclier qui est là pour
protéger les entreprises et protéger les
ménages donc ça c'est une dimension
qu'on ne peut pas nier qui fait partie
du paquet européen et qui va donner des
résultats effectivement pas du jour au
lendemain mais qui est qui est la partie
intégrante de ce plan donc l'idée c'est
on essaie de limiter l'augmentation on
peut évidemment elle est elle reste
inévitable alors justement pour revenir
un peu sur les mesures annoncées par
obsola vanderleion
vous allez nous expliquer Sabine qu'il
est parce qu'il y en a deux d'après ce
que j'ai compris une sur les super
profits des entreprises productrices
d'énergie fossiles donc on ne connaît
pas quelle sera cette taxe mais
normalement il devrait y avoir une taxe
donc sur ces super profits et puis
l'autre c'est le plafonnement des
revenus des producteurs d'électricité
mais cette fois ce sont les producteurs
d'électricité nucléaire est de
renouvelables qui en fait engrange des
bénéfices exceptionnels parce que
j'imagine le prix de l'électricité est
lié à celui du gaz dans ce piquez-nous
en fait je pense que il s'agit surtout
aussi de d'éviter à ce que certaines
puissent profiter d'une situation
inventaire involontairement parfois
aussi pas forcément consciemment c'est
et on voit bien aussi que notre marché
de l'électricité en fait aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne plus comme il la fonctionné à
un moment donné puisque couplet
électricité enfin le prix de
l'électricité au prix du gaz aujourd'hui
c'est préjudiciable donc de toute
manière il faut qu'on trouve une
solution pour sortir de ça donc il y
aura un plafonnement du prix en fait
pour parler ça donc ce que elle a
annoncé et en plus il y aura donc
d'après les premières estimations et là
je peux que me fier à ce que vous allez
faire la Une a dit il y aura quand même
140 milliards d'euros de ce taxation sur
les super profits comme on dit qu'ils
doivent venir alimenter en fait les
aides au profit des ménages mais aussi
des entreprises mais ça c'est ce qu'on a
entendu aujourd'hui
quels seront les mesures
qui sont en place avant que ça arrive
chez nous dans le terrain parce que
c'est ça aussi qu'on attend nous en tant
que député nationale j'ai envie de dire
toute politique infinie et politique
locale et nous on doit savoir comment on
fait pour que ça arrive vraiment chez
nous là on était encore dans les grands
principes en dehors de là justement de
l'enveloppe globale qui était de dire
qu'il y aurait 140 milliards d'économies
cet art maintenant qu'on voit très bien
entre l'échelon national et l'échelon
européen les mesures deviennent
complémentaires justement puisqu'on
assouplit ses règles de concurrence
d'aide d'État ça permet justement aux
États nationaux d'agir il y a plus de
flexibilité ce qu'on n'avait pas avant
François Gmail bienvenue sur France 24
professeur à Sciences Po et à
l'Université Libre de Bruxelles
spécialiste de géopolitique de
l'environnement et également membre du
GIEC vous prenez le débat en cours on
est déjà en plein en plein débat sur
justement les mesures annoncées par
Ursula anderleion sur l'énergie donc
vous tombez très bien peut-être que vous
allez nous expliquer ce mécanisme dont
elle parle qui est de celui de plafonner
les revenus des producteurs
d'électricité nucléaire et renouvelables
et une fois que ce plafond est fixé et
bien utilisé la différence de revenus
pour financer donc une politique
énergétique en fait le but de tout ça
c'est de limiter l'augmentation des prix
j'ai envie de dire c'est surtout de
réorienter une masse d'argent parce
quand on parle des surprofions on parle
évidemment d'abord des sur profils et
compagnies gazières et pétrolières mais
il ne faut pas oublier que les
producteurs d'énergie nucléaires ou
renouvelables c'est à dire qu'ils ne
dépendaient pas du gaz ont réalisé aussi
des profits tout à fait important
puisqu'il n'était pas concernés par
l'augmentation du prix du gaz et donc
l'idée effectivement c'est aussi en
quelque sorte de taxé c'est sur profits
en fixant un plafond maximum de revenus
et ce qui est au-dessus du plafond on le
prend pour le réel ou ailleurs alors
justement quel plafond elle a pas donné
de prix justement
à partir de quel moment est-ce qu'un
profit devient un sur profit qu'est-ce
qu'on considère comme un profit normal
est-ce qu'on va le faire une moyenne des
dernières années est-ce qu'on va avoir
une décision arbitraire je dirais c'est
un peu le propre d'un discours sur
l'état de l'Union c'est de fixer des
grands principes après tout va se jouer
évidemment dans l'application alors
justement il vaut aussi d'après ce qu'il
y avait annoncé Emmanuel Macron la
semaine dernière une coopération
européenne par exemple entre la France
et l'Allemagne par exemple la France va
acheter de l'électricité à l'Allemagne
même si on va en reparler il y a quand
même des centrales à charbon en
Allemagne donc d'un point de vue
environnemental c'est peut-être pas
formidable mais enfin et l'Allemagne va
acheter du gaz à la France ça va être ça
un petit peu il va y avoir des des
accords entre les différents étapes pour
s'en sortir bah il y a d'abord une
approche européenne par exemple la
plateforme d'achat conjoint de gaz et
autres qui est déjà mis sur la table et
qui va être encore activé un peu plus et
puis bien sûr jouer sur les
interconnexions parce qu'on a un marché
et une géopolitique une cartographie des
connexions européennes qui vont être
utilisées à plan qui sont déjà utilisés
à plein et donc effectivement l'exemple
que vous citiez avec une un support
croisé entre États membres entre le gaz
électricité entre la France et
l'Allemagne et entre d'autres
puisqu'effectivement tous n'ont pas par
exemple le même niveau de dépendance
vis-à-vis du gaz russe et non pas les
mêmes capacités de production que ce
soit renouvelables et autres c'est le
marché vraiment de l'énergie c'est
l'union c'est un aspect important parce
pense que on voit bien à quel point
l'absence d'une vraie politique
énergétique européenne a été un talon
d'Achille dans cette crise parce qu'on
avait 27 pays avec 27 politiques
énergétiques très différentes les unes
des autres
en l'occurrence en Allemagne en
Allemagne en Allemagne en Italie en
Autriche l'Autriche indépendante à 100 %
par exemple du gaz russe et de l'autre
côté des pays plus avancés sur leur
ouvrage ou plus d'éclairés or l'Europe
c'est quand même construite à partir de
coopération énergétique la séga au
départ c'est une le ratum comparation
dans le domaine de l'énergie atomique
c'est comme si on avait un peu oublié au
cours de la construction européenne
cette coopération en matière énergétique
et évidemment elle revient forcément par
la fenêtre après avoir été chassé par la
porte est-ce qu'on sait justement à quel
tarif le gaz l'électricité globalement
seront plafonnées au niveau européen
parce qu'on va revenir sur les mesures
françaises François Jemen est-ce qu'il y
a un objectif difficile à dire
il est clair que la multiplication par 3
ou par 4 des prix du gaz et
l'électricité n'est pas tenable la
question c'est à quel niveau est-ce
qu'on va revenir on sait que le gaz
électricité était plutôt très bon marché
avant la crise est-ce qu'on va revenir à
ce niveau-là est-ce qu'on va revenir à
un niveau intermédiaire sachant que la
transition énergétique se fera plus
facilement si le gaz est plutôt bon
marché on va écouter Elisabeth borne
puisqu'elle s'est exprimée aujourd'hui
la première ministre française justement
sur cette question de la hausse des
tarifs du gaz et de l'électricité nous
allons prolonger en 2023 le mécanisme de
bouclier tarifaire pour tous les ménages
pour les copropriétés les logements
sociaux les petites entreprises et les
plus petites communes
nous allons ainsi limiter les hausses de
prix à 15% pour le gaz en janvier 2023
et à 15% pour l'électricité en février
15% au lieu de
120%, c'est l'engagement que nous
prenons
l'écart ne sera pas reportée sur les
factures des consommateurs en 2024 ou
plus tard il sera pris en charge par
l'État Valérie drus donc prise en charge
par l'État une hausse de 15% en 2023 au
lieu donc du double ou du triple d'après
ce que disait la première ministre mais
c'est plus pour l'instant on en était un
bouclier à 4%. donc il y aura une
augmentation bah écoutez bon ça ce sont
les mesures nationales mais beaucoup la
plupart des États membres en fait ont
pris des mesures de soutien au ménage
notamment quel que soit la formule qui a
été recueillie et ce dont on parlait
précédemment est très important parce
que ce routage de défoncs qui vont être
prélevés vont permettre justement de
réinjecter de permettre aux États
membres de maintenir ce soutien grosso
modo actuellement on est à peu près 200
milliards qui ont été injectés par les
États membres pour soutenir les ménages
on parlait de 140 milliards donc on
commence à avoir un niveau d'échelle qui
va permettre justement de pérenniser ce
type de soutien pour faire que les
factures sont moins difficiles bien
qu'effectivement ne soient pas
compensées totalement ces métiers
[Musique]
pas nous dans lequel on était là
des boucliers tarifaires évidemment il
faut le faire on peut pas laisser de
sombrer des ménages dans la pauvreté ni
des entreprises fermées mais il faut
bien se rendre compte que tout cet
argent ce sont des cadeaux qui sont
faits aux firmes pétrolières et gazières
et une finesse c'est de l'argent qui ne
sera pas investi dans la transition
énergétique et ce sont des montants
considérables 24 milliards en France 65
milliards en Allemagne tout ça c'est de
l'argent malheureusement un peu jeté par
les fenêtres pour ceux qui ont ça notre
monde d'anticipation auparavant
probablement bien entendu on est le dos
mur acculé acculé mesure de
transformation François Germaine
également inclus dans le plan de Ursula
Vander Leon c'est usine solaire en
Sicile alors ça c'est important ou pas
et puis des trains régionaux à
l'hydrogène vers doubler l'objectif pour
l'hydrogène alors l'hydrogène c'est
important ça peut être vraiment être une
énergie du futur c'est un sacré Paris
que fait l'Union européenne et ours
d'investir dans cette technologie qui
effectivement peut être très
intéressante notamment dans le domaine
de l'aviation potentiellement dans le
domaine des trains et d'autres
transports je dirais de masse qui n'est
pas encore mature pour le moment et donc
on espère qu'elle le sera bientôt mais
très clairement l'Europe essaye de
s'affirmer comme leader sur cette
énergie parce qu'elle sait qu'elle a
laissé le train passer sur le fauteuil
et sur l'éolien l'Europe était jadis en
première ligne dans le développement du
photovoltaïque et puis abandonner ses
investissements et aujourd'hui c'est la
Chine qui produit l'essentiel des
panneaux photovoltaïques mais pour
l'hydrogène pour produire de l'hydrogène
il faut du gaz oui donc en quoi est-elle
véritablement propre et puis en plus
est-ce que c'est pour le moment disons
qu'il y a plusieurs types d'hydrogène on
va distinguer l'hydrogène vert
l'hydrogène bleue etc il y a moyen d'en
produire de façon relativement propre la
question c'est comment le distribuer et
comment le stocker parce qu'on sait que
c'est un gaz qui reste encore un peu
assez instable pour le moment
ce sont des nouvelles mesures qui vont
vers de l'énergie renouvelable elle a
parlé vraiment d'un paquet un accord
mondial ambitieux pour la nature c'est
ce qu'a dit sous la forme Verlaine c'est
très ambitieux enfin en tout cas sur
l'objectif il y a plusieurs aspects
d'abord pour revenir sur cette question
de l'hydrogène entre autres ce qui est
important de garder en tête c'est on a
parlé de diversification des
approvisionnements mais on parle des
diversification de sources d'énergie
donc ça doit être vu comme un bouquet on
parle d'hydrogène aujourd'hui parce
qu'effectivement il y a cette ce pari de
faire de l'hydrogène vert à partir de
l'électricité qui sont produites de
manière verte et si je puis dire
rapidement donc pas de gaz et d'investir
maintenant et d'investir maintenant
justement dans la phase suivante pour
tout de suite avoir les infrastructures
quand la technologie est complètement
mature pour pouvoir justement sauter
tout de suite ce pas immédiatement mais
il faut pas oublier les autres sources
d'énergie c'est pour ça qu'elle
rappelait c'est c'est c'est
ces usines photovol
les au Danemark aussi les éoliennes pour
rappeler qu'il y a cet ensemble de
bouquets et cette augmentation qui a été
voulue cette accélération de la part des
renouvelables jusqu'à 45% en 2030 mais
ça c'est un aspect qui est très
important toujours cet anniversaire
c'est 2030 donc là on est dans le moyen
terme mais on est déjà proche des 45%.
on avance ça je crois qu'il faut quand
même garder cette boussole et le fait
qu'il y a une progression il a une
accélération et on a tendance à Mith qui
laisse c'est la sobriété alors elle a
pas je ne sais pas je suis pas sûre
d'avoir entendu ce terme elle l'a
utilisé ce terme de sobriété parce qu'on
l'entend beaucoup en France bien sûr et
l'Allemagne
elle a parlé de réduction mais pas de
sobriété mais je crois que ça ça reste
quand même vrai qu'on doit faire des
efforts et que certaines efforts je
crois que ça nous nous coûterons pas sur
enfin là je dis je suis pas une
spécialiste de l'énergie vous allez
peut-être
contredire mais quand tu entends que
rien qu'en langue l'éveil de nos
appareils on pourrait
économiser l'énergie de plusieurs
centrales nucléaires c'est un appel
quand même
multiplier par
des millions d'habitants dans l'Union
européenne ou même rien que chez nous
c'est énorme au niveau de l'entreprise
au niveau du particulier enfin je veux
dire c'est pas un sacrifice à demander à
une catégorie particulière de personnes
mais tous ensemble et c'est le retour de
mesures de lutte anti-gaspillage au fond
qu'on appelait avant de lecture
maintenant il faut aller plus loin il
faut aussi une sobriété qui passe par
des politiques publiques notamment des
politiques publiques de rénovation des
logements c'est que dans plusieurs pays
le parc immobilier est en très mauvais
état et donc il y a aussi une vraie
question sociale là derrière parce qu'on
est avec des passoires énergétiques en
hiver donc des factures qui explosent
sur les ménages et en été on est dans
des fous et les gens qui cuisent
littéralement à l'intérieur de
l'appartement surtout que ce sont
souvent des des classes populaires qui
parfois n'ont pas les moyens de partir
en vacances si je veux juste ça montre
exactement le problème devant lequel
nous nous sommes nous devons protéger
donc
utiliser nos moyens financiers pour la
protection pour les boucliers etc et en
même temps garder une capacité
d'investissement parce que sinon on va
pas s'en sortir parce qu'on a besoin
cette rénovation donc vous parlez on a
besoin
tout un tas de mesure pour aller de
l'avant
si je peux me permettre elle est déjà en
cours parce qu'effectivement dans le
plan post crise covid pour relancer
l'économie européenne en puissance 800
milliards mis sur la table là transition
et la protection des des voilà
disparition des passoires thermiques
et par exemple le plan français le plan
de relance qui est donc bénéficie de 40%
de soutien européen a financer ma prime
rénove et justement s'occupe directement
de la précarité énergétique donc c'est
déjà quelque chose ce qui est en route
oui ils sont en route François gémen
mais on n'y est pas quand même dans
l'exécution sur
on en est loin de volonté politique mais
sur l'application notamment en France on
en a encore très très loin à mon avis
c'est une des mesures les plus efficaces
que le gouvernement pourrait prendre
pour permettre à la France d'atteindre
ses objectifs de l'accord de Paris et
quand on dit finalement tout dépendra de
la rudesse de l'hiver finalement les
Français sont suspendus à la météo cet
hiver c'est quand même assez incroyable
il était déjà cet été pour d'autres
raisons c'est à dire que l'information
météorologique qui jadis était
considérée un peu comme une information
presque quasiment de divertissement on
engageait d'ancienne Miss France pour
faire les bulletins météo et pour donner
les éphémérites aujourd'hui devient une
information de plus en plus complexe et
de plus en plus essentiel pour la vie
des gens et donc je pense qu'il y a
vraiment matière à retravailler aussi en
matière d'information les bulletins
météo pour que toute une série
d'informations notamment sur le climat
ou sur l'énergie soit communiquée en
même temps
que bien sûr les températures et la
météo mais est-ce qu'on a encore besoin
de savoir que c'est la sainte île de
main et la saint Benjamin après-demain
je ne suis pas sûr encore une fois je
reviens un petit peu au début est-ce que
les populations européennes vont rester
mobilisées si effectivement il y a des
coupures de gaz coupures d'électricité
si l'hiver est très rude et qu'on ne
peut plus se chauffer alors je pense
qu'il faut quand même rappeler même si
tout n'est pas parfait même si c'est
difficile que par exemple au niveau des
stockages de gage qu'on rappelait
précédemment on avait fixé cet objectif
d'avoir 80% de stockage de gaz de
réserve au 1er novembre on a dépassé cet
objectif donc ça c'est déjà fait la
mobilisation était rapide et je ne suis
pas sûr qu'à l'époque beaucoup aurai
parié sur le fait qu'on atteigne ce
résultat donc il faut le noter c'est à
dire qu'en terme d'inquiétude je veux
pas dire que tout est bien sûr réglé
bien entendu mais un niveau d'inquiétude
qui est beaucoup qui est bien moindre en
termes d'impact de capacité d'avoir de
l'énergie de pouvoir se chauffer grâce à
ce stockage et les mesures de d'économie
qui vont venir justement aux heures de
pointe pour diminuer aussi la
consommation c'est un ensemble de
mesures qui vont faire que maintenant on
est mieux engagé que peut-être on
l’était il y a quelques semaines mais
vraiment il faut rappeler cette donne
aussi aux Français on est obligé
d'ouvrir une centrale à charbon en
France celle d'avold est-ce que les
centrales nucléaires vont fonctionner
puisque elles sont il y en a quoi une
douzaine qui était à l'arrêt plus il y
en a aujourd'hui 30 qui sont à l'arrêt
sur sur 56 réacteurs au total donc plus
de la moitié du parc nucléaire français
est à l'arrêt soit pour des problèmes de
corrosion soit pour des questions de
maintenance qui avait été retardées à
cause de la crise du covid et quelque
part on voit bien tout le paradoxe de la
situation c'est que notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles nous place dans une
situation de très grande dépendance et
de très grandes faiblesses où on est
suspendu quelque part au fait de savoir
si l'hiver va être plus ou moins rude
comme vous le rappeliez si nous avions
fait la transition énergétique pour des
raisons climatiques il y a 20 ou 30 ans
et évidemment nous n'en serions pas là
alors il y a désormais un facteur
géostratégique puissant qui rajoute
comme argument on se rend compte que
cette transition énergétique c'est la
condition aussi de mettre fin à notre
faiblesse géostratégique une condition
de souveraineté parfois avec justement
cette ennemi dont vous parlez cet
adversaire puisqu'on rouvre des centres
à charbon pour pouvoir se chauffer des
hivers il y a 20 ans on est obligé
aujourd'hui de revenir en arrière et de
faire des choses qui sont
fondamentalement contre-productives par
rapport à l'objectif final sabine-t-il à
vous qui êtes franco-allemande
intéressante d'avoir justement le point
de vue de l'Allemande que vous êtes
aussi parce que eux ils ont dû
effectivement faire un virage à 180
degrés puisque il comptait beaucoup sur
le gaz russe et il rouvre des centrales
à charbon une électricité d'ailleurs
qu'on va nous-mêmes même apporter nous
Français effectivement ouvrir les
centrales à charbon c'est vrai que ça
fait très mal maintenant il faut pas
oublier non plus par contre que
l'Allemagne a quand même massivement
investi dans les énergies renouvelables
et 40 millions 49% quand même
d'électricité
est fournie par du renouvelable là nous
loin donc ça veut dire que c'est un peu
effectivement le grand écart quand on
regarde la lumière
par exemple effectivement le nucléaire à
chaque fois que je discute avec mes
collègues allemands c'est une fin de non
recevoir même si monsieur rabek commence
à dire oui bah on n'aura pas le choix de
toute manière enfin l'Allemagne n'aura
pas le choix de quand même réouvrir
éventuellement ou de ne pas arrêter les
derniers centrales nucléaires mais il y
a une réponse
dans la population qui est qui est
extrêmement fort par contre disons que
je dis et vous allez par exemple en
Bavière c'est assez étonnant quand vous
voyagez
des toits à perte de vue des
particuliers avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques ou solaire
on va bien par exemple la Bavière la
Bavière me vient
mais mais ailleurs aussi mais c'est en
Bavière j'ai voyagé récemment et ça m'a
frappé voilà 180 degrés et que fait
l'Allemagne c'est aussi en termes de
politique étrangère en réalité
l'Allemagne a longtemps lié sa politique
énergétique à sa politique étrangère
avec la Russie en s'imaginant en
appliquant les principes de Montesquieu
que si l'on faisait du commerce avec son
ennemi et bien on allait pacifier les
relations et il faut dire que c'est
aussi pour ça que il y a quelque part de
tels liens entre l'Allemagne et la
Russie en matière de politique
énergétique où la Russie a envoyé des
agents en Allemagne à recruter d'anciens
ou dirigeants allemands guerre au
conseil d'administration gaz pro mais
évidemment le plus connu bélier en a
d'autres le problème c'est que en cas de
désaccord majeur Vladimir Poutine
manifestement n'a que faire du de sa
relation commerciale avec l'Allemagne et
préfère poursuivre des intérêts
nationalistes Sabine on apprend là à
l'instant que la première ministre suéd
je reconnais la victoire du bloc de
droite et d’extrême droite et qu'elle
donne sa démission on parlait au début
de cette émission justement des valeurs
démocratiques de l'Europe vraiment mis
en exergue par
Ursula vanderlayen peut-être que il y
aura aussi un parti d'extrême droite en
Italie très bientôt au pouvoir on
parlait d'Orban est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
alors que on brandit cette menace russe
et certains ont de partis plutôt proche
d'ailleurs de Vladimir Poutine est-ce
que ça ne menace pas cette unité
européenne mais je crois que c'était
vraiment le exactement le message de la
présidente à la fin de son discours le
dire effectivement on est en train de
s'opposer à une autocratie de la
désinformation de la de la manipulation
mais on doit aussi balayer devant notre
porte si je peux utiliser cette
expression et quand elle parlait de la
protection de l'État de droit déjà lors
du discours de l'année dernière elle
avait modifié le rapport de l'État de
droit pour inclure des recommandations
aux États membres c'est tout à fait
nouveau c'était la première fois
en juillet donc en juillet 2022 et le
fait qu'elle est singularisée dans dans
ce rapport la corruption comme étant un
domaine de travail interne je crois que
c'est un message très clair pour dire ne
sont pas ici pour donner des leçons nous
sommes aussi ici pour être un exemple et
nous allons suivre je parlais tout à
l'heure des mesures d'infraction que
nous pouvons prendre les mesures de
contestionnalité que dont on a parlé de
la surveillance de la liberté de la
presse puisqu'il y a aussi un acte une
loi sur la liberté de la presse qui sera
adoptée lundi un ensemble de mesures qui
fait nous sommes aussi vigilant
l'interne et très actif donc il
durcissement parce que ça fait un moment
qu'on parle de sanction contre les
Polonais et contrôler hongrois et bon
finalement ça va vraiment arriver il va
y avoir c'est sur les fonds ces fameux
aides financières que ça va fonctionner
en parlant précédemment effectivement
c'est c'est une des mesures qui peut
arriver dans dans le cas hongrois que
vous citiez pour le reste les
infractions suivent leur cours et aussi
les États membres répondent leur
législation pour se conformer à ce qui a
demandait aussi au niveau au niveau des
infractions donc dans ce cas là on
revient finalement à la normalité
Sabine Tillet cette montée manifestement
de l'extrême droite en Europe en Suède
bon mais plusieurs probablement en
Italie aussi c'est moi je trouve c'est
très inquiétant quand même parce que ça
veut dire que on l'a vu aussi lors de
nos élections récent les législatives
moi personnellement j'avais une
candidate du rassemblement national en
face de moi il y a deux conceptions qui
qui se confrontent les uns qui disent
comme nous qui disent on peut
réussir dans ce monde qu'ensemble en
tant que Union européenne en mettant nos
forces ensemble comme on l'a fait
pendant la pandémie et comme on le fait
maintenant et il y en a d'autres qui
disent non c'est pas possible il faut
qu'on ramène ses compétences au niveau
national c'est là tout seul qu'on peut
réussir moi je comprends pas très bien
la logique mais c'est une réalité et
cette réalité malheureusement elle est
présente dans beaucoup d'États membres
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que quand même
il y a un message nous arrivons pas à
passer et ça il va falloir qu'on y
réfléchisse très très rapidement
on se rend compte avec le covid avec la
crise énergétique avec la guerre en
Ukraine qu'on a besoin de plus d'Europe
que jamais quelque part on voit que les
lignes bougent sur toute une série de
dossiers a commencé par la politique
énergétique mais aussi la politique
d'élargissement et dans le même temps
les électeurs dans plusieurs pays
européens importants pour dire non on
veut moins d'Europe on ne veut plus
entendre parler d'Europe on veut
gouverner tout seul et l'autre paradoxe
c'est que aujourd'hui le climat est
devenu une préoccupation essentielle des
Européens chacun se rend bien compte de
l'urgence et quelque part les électeurs
dans plusieurs pays vont voter contre le
climat il n'y a pas de partie qui
s'occupe moins de location climatique
que les parties extrêmes droites qui
sont souvent d'ailleurs assez
climato-sceptiques nous commençons
remonter ce paradoxe quand on est face à
une guerre
sur le climat je pense que la démocratie
atteint un certain limite et qu'il va
falloir passer davantage par la voix des
entreprises et des collectivités et
malheureusement ne pas trop attendre de
gouvernement qui ne reçoivent pas de
mandats très fort pour lutter contre le
changement climatique et en même temps
les contraintes ces entreprises
justement et à faire de la sobriété je
pense qu'elle réalise qu'elles ont un
intérêt vital aussi et je vois le
discours d'entreprise changer beaucoup
en disant c'est plus tellement une
affaire de réglementation on réalise que
c'est dans notre intérêt d'être durable
aujourd'hui parce que si on n'est pas on
ne sera pas non plus profitable demain
mais on parle de contraint justement
parce qu'elles vont pas assez loin un
mot sur l'élargissement de l'Europe elle
en a parlé également qui doit l'Europe
doit accueillir les Balkans la Moldavie
la Géorgie elle doit s'élargir à dire
sous la forme derlion donc est-ce que
c'est possible est-ce qu'elle en a les
moyens cette Europe ecoutez on se posait
les mêmes questions en 2004 avec grand
élargissement
l'Europe a continué maintenant elle a
dit elle a dit deux choses c'est
l'intégration de ces c'est l'avenir de
l'Europe aussi et en même temps elle a
dit elle a appelé à une convention pour
voir comment leur fonctionne donc je
pense que les deux aspects sont sur la
table très clairement dans ce discours
et pour dire oui il y a une vocation
politique il y a aussi un processus
d'élargissement qui est très clair et
qui fait que il faut passer par un
certain nombre de preuves de capacité au
niveau économique de respect de la règle
de droit avant d'entrer dans la maison
Europe c'est une vocation la Commission
en particulier aide l'ensemble des pays
candidats et puis en même temps appeler
à voir comment nos institutions
fonctionnent pour être sûr effectivement
qu'on puisse garder une fonctionnalité
elle a tendue évidemment la main à
l'Ukraine on le sait pour justement
cette qu'elle puisse être membre en tout
cas pouvoir commencer à rentrer dans le
processus d'entrer dans l'Union
européenne mais la Géorgie la Moldavie
normalement et la prochaine aussi les
Balkans qui eux demandent depuis
longtemps de rentrer dans cette Europe
une Europe à 27
c'est déjà compliqué c'est c'est très
compliqué mais le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui il faut un courage politique
aussi par rapport à ça parce qu'on peut
pas se permettre en nos frontières des
zones d'instabilité on a on a besoin un
voisinage stable par contre nous devons
aussi réfléchir à nos institutions
qu'elle soit nationale ou européen
justement parce que ça a bien fonctionné
pendant un certain temps mais
aujourd'hui les questions qui se posent
comment aurons-nous nous nous
compatriotes on peut pas aller contre
eux on peut avoir des les meilleures
idées du monde si on emmène pas le monde
on aboutit à rien donc une réflexion
comment articuler démocratie
participative avec démocratie
représentative
européen aussi cette règle de
l'unanimité évidemment s'il y a d'autres
États membres qui nous rejoignent la
règle de l'unanimité ça va être terrible
parce que ça va être un risque de
blocage donc de toute manière là il est
temps réfléchi tout en même temps parce
que sinon on court quand même des
risques franchement
il y a encore un an qu'on irait si
rapidement vers les agissements il y a
un an tout le monde semblait dire on a
élargi trop vite il faut d'abord
approfondir et on fait une pause sur
l'élargissement et là il semble y avoir
un compte sensu ça c'est large que je
partage pour dire qu'il faut accueillir
l'Ukraine et puis la Moldavie dans la
famille européenne et donc on voit à
quel point les lignes bougent très très
rapidement sur ce sujet l'autre question
c'est de savoir si ça va vous jouer
aussi sur la question de la politique
d'asile et d'immigration qui est un
autre nœud gordien de dans la politique
européenne
ça reste très sensible mais l'accueil
des réfugiés Ukrainiens qui étaient
remarquables à mazégard prouve que
l'accueil des réfugiés c'était pas
seulement une question de capacité mais
surtout une question de volonté merci
beaucoup François Germaine merci Sabine
Tillet Merci à VOUS Valérie de raiset
humez d'avoir participé à ce débat merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis vous restez
avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]